[Applaus]
sie sind krank und wollen nichts als
leben
sie warten auf ein organ dass ein
verstorbener spendet
ein leben geht zu ende
eines wird verlängert die
organtransplantation ist ein eingriff
der bewegt es geht um ethik glaube
gesetz und moral
um großes glück
ich freue mich darauf wie verrückt jetzt
auf diesen nächsten abschnitt in meinem
leben und bin sehr dankbar dass ich das
alles erleben darf und um ängste was
bedeutet die transplantation für die
empfängerinnen und empfänger wie genau
läuft sie ab um zirka 20 nach 8
und die leben ist schön
[Musik]
wahnsinnig geduld
wie es die lebensqualität nach dem
großen eingriff es geht um warten
hoffnung und vielleicht erlösung
[Musik]
so viel leid dass ich nicht immer dieses
starke for building für dass mich viele
hier halten
man fange ja da habe ich ganz gehörig
die schnauze voll momente in denen ich
als meinen körper ausbrechen und ganz
weit weg rennen möchte und vielleicht
einfach auch einmal ein bisschen normal
sein will
eliane gutzweiler ist 26 jahre alt
sie leidet an der lungenkrankheit system
fibrose
vor fünf jahren wurde ihr eine
spenderlunge transplantiert nach langem
warten mit dem leben hatte sie damals
schon abgeschlossen
all diese erlebnisse teilt sie mit ihren
followern gruppe thema und inhalt die
therapie von jedermann us macher der
neben psychisch problem hat sie
vielleicht probieren erläutert klare wie
das ist grund fallen also hauptsächlich
sichere verarbeitung und ihn mit dem
profil ergänzt nun gegen die normalität
heißt elias blog
es geht um kleider frisuren rezepte und
krankheit
ja gemerkt hat dass sie mit dem lüd
machen aber vielleicht selber bis hand
und muss gleich ein wenig unser licht
noch nie transplantiert sind einfach
gefährlich kraft schenken und ihnen
zeigen darf sondern dass man alle person
ich schade
eliane gutzweiler möchte leben wie alle
anderen auch aber der körper macht ihr
einen strich durch die rechnung
er will die transplantierte lunge nicht
mehr akzeptieren
chronische abstoß sich und für das
gerade jetzt in eine sogenannte
lichttherapie wo wir wissen wirklich so
verändert werden dass sie noch länger
wirken und das duett halten und für das
paket das gefühl oder vielmehr rucksack
chronische abstoßung
ein schock aber kein todesurteil sagt
eliane
die handwerker wie lange das mit dem
abstoßen klappen aber das haben wir ja
so steht also kann jetzt dadurch vor der
fusion und der azubi oder
[Musik]
die diagnose hat eliane gutzwiller
zurückgeworfen aber die neue therapie
hält die chronische abstoßung in schach
foto veh reese heißt die behandlung eine
art blutwäsche die weißen blutzellen
werden außerhalb des körpers mit einer
substanz versetzt und mit uv licht
bestrahlt
dafür braucht eliane einen sogenannten
port ein katheter system unter der haut
[Musik]
eliane hat import einen namen gegeben
jason justin die therapie macht müde
andere nebenwirkungen hat sie nicht die
foto friese kann die chronische
abstoßung nicht zum verschwinden bringen
aber immerhin bremsen es geht mir
hoffnung
das blut läuft durch diese maschine
eliane gibt nicht auf
im schweizerischen kinder leber zentrum
in genf warten maria und ihre elternzeit
tagen sehnsüchtig auf die erlaubnis
heimzukehren
dank des aufstiegs seit sie das areal
leidet an einer gefährlichen krankheit
nur eine lebertransplantation kann sie
retten
der eingriff läuft gut nach einer woche
aber gibt es komplikationen miriam muss
noch mal operiert werden
die zeit im spital ist für alle schwer
[Musik]
die arzt visite ist überfällig
einen monat verbringt die ganze familie
jetzt schon im spital
wir sind damit für die einrichtung und
danach richtung habe ich habe mich
verstand mit französischer und dem wie
dirk lütter hier und dann für sich die
tabellenführung
[Gelächter]
es braucht eine kontrolle pro woche bis
drei monate nach der transplantation
kontrollen die innenstadt finden können
früher schon gesagt haben
im fall von fieber erbrechen oder
durchfall müssen sie immer ins spital
ein dankeschön
[Musik]
die route wird berechnet
jahrelang hatten die eltern angst mir
eher zu verlieren
sie hofften auf die transplantation
banken während der eingriffe
jetzt endlich ist es vorbei es geht nach
hause
[Musik]
wenn ich sehe wie ich und wie viel
arbeit aber knapp
[Musik]
ankunft in emmenbrücke
matthias bruder hat die wohnung und hund
rocco behütet katja schimpft die wohnung
ist hier nicht sauber genug
[Musik]
vor allem die küche raus blitzblank
werden
marias abwehrkräfte sind geschwächt
[Musik]
rapperswil am zürichsee christian
reutemann wartet auf eine spenderlunge
das ist mist mobile sauerstoffgerät
jetzt garnicht posco hole ist ein
telefon und mit notfall sprich die sache
nicht immer denn ich wusste dass er gar
so dass ich immer bei dem kater
reutemann ist 51 seit zehn jahren leidet
er an copd einer chronisch obstruktiven
lungenkrankheit
das haus hat keinen lift bewegung jetzt
zur qual
das ist station eis haben wir euch
eigentlich irgendwas poisel rund um die
uhr ist er auf das sauerstoffgerät
angewiesen die frage beantworten
sie führt somit bin ich würd ich sie
nicht merkt an ich hoffe das bringt
genauso wenig
man muss versuchen das positive zu sehen
[Musik]
obwohl der krankheit geht es ja
eigentlich nur eine prognose spd ist
unheilbar
christian reutemann er ist vor zwei
jahren zerbrochen
seine ex frau ist aber immer noch tag
und nacht für ihn da wenn er in atemnot
gerät
das leben ist geschrumpft
[Musik]
die arbeit als leitender angestellter in
der von tchibo musste er vor vier jahren
aufgeben
die wohnung verlässt er kaum mehr
früher spielte christian reutemann tuwa
unter anderem auch bei der stadtmusik
rapperswil
er habe wild gelebt geraucht und gekifft
dazu steht er die gedanklich noch
braucht und so weiter kann ich mir
gemacht allerdings mit 21 gibt es sturm
war so ein bisschen erhöht wie ich
zumindest das hat copd fördere aber nur
leichte snacks rund 90 prozent der copd
patienten haben geraucht oder rauchen
immer noch neben der musik war eine
modelleisenbahn das große hobby von
christian reutemann zurzeit aber steht
alles still
nach der transplantation geht's ohne
tore
lotter bahnhof da werden abgestellt
der wandel da können so viel macht und
der große kreis der bauernhof harry kunz
sich dank der region da und da geht es
doch schön fahrstrecke da haben schon
große dokumente gehören das ziel von der
kooperation
es fehlt ihm die kraft die anlage
zusammen zu setzen
die kiosk separat belüftet die große
beleuchtet das ist sind sagen wir mit
den anderen setzen kann machen aber da
baue machen das schaf jetzt ein held
ja
[Musik]
christian reutemann ist seit fast einem
jahr auf der warteliste für eine
lungentransplantation zurzeit mit 45
anderen patientinnen und patienten
die durchschnittliche wartezeit beträgt
gut ein jahr
[Musik]
auf der intensivstation des inselspitals
bern liegt ein patient im koma sein sohn
erinnert sich monate später an den
dramatischen tag
die nächste aktion ist der winter ski
fahre halt es wird dunkel deine bevor es
dunkel ist finden weil im moment dank
mit dem halter bei brauchen das
doppelpaket und das hat er immer dabei
das nimmt zu so steigen roboter züchten
und wir handeln aber nie erreicht und
immer wieder probiert und irgendein ist
hat er abgenommen - wieder probiert hat
und den ich sehen so später auf sie und
hat sich gefragt was ist los und
hirnblutungen so die diagnose
schnell war klar dass der vater von
patrick von reding nicht überleben wird
die ärzte sprachen mit den angehörigen
über eine organspende die familie stimmt
dazu
der hirnschaden bei irreversibel der
hirntod aber noch nicht eingetreten
damit dürfte auch der organspende
prozessen noch nicht gestartet werden
genauso da meine patienten mit
internationalen blutig mit dem entdecker
lee bruch dann redakteur gespräche
geführt und dem simplen patient jetzt
ein organ erhalten die therapie
gehöriges in dem moment immer noch da
sind einfach gut informiert organ
erhalten der therapie
das heißt der patient bleibt an den
maschinen er wird beatmet der kreislauf
stabilisiert die familie des patienten
muss erinnert stunden entscheiden ob
eine organspende in frage kam oder nicht
red kein ubs kaufte das haus christie's
das heißt noch nicht dass müsste der weg
gen norden spannend machen
aber mich an chris coras ganze
balancieren hilfsbereiter mensch selber
quelle haufe und mir hat das wäre ist
ihm sinkt sie denn trotz aller
traurigkeit und wenn manch anderen
eigentlich anderen kaufen und zu dem er
ist eigentlich ein quasi und technik und
organspende
wer die nachricht erhält dass ein
geliebter mensch verstorben sei ist
schnell überfordert wenn in einem
zweiten gespräch die frage nach einer
organspende kommt oft wissen die
angehörigen nicht was der verstorbene
wollte matthias aebischer ist mit
solchen situationen vertraut auch für
die intensivmediziner können die
gespräche belastend seien betroffen
lautet wie druck organspende showbiz des
rheintals das brot medizin
ich hab das nicht absolvierte für sich
selber muss entscheiden
und wenn er das wort der täter soll
merklich an sobald die zustimmung für
eine organspende da ist läuft eine frist
von 48 stunden tritt der hirntod in
dieser zeit nicht ein
lässt man den patienten sterben war
fristlos oder definiert wurden ich will
ja es ist zum teil nicht klar wie sich
das entwickelt mit dem hirndruck das
kann man ganz schnell da und mein
geschnitten so ist das ganz gut wenn man
weiß man nur für 48 stunden
und wenn es nach 48 stunden mit der hier
in novi tritt dann leider kann spaß
machen wenn das der wunsch von patienten
[Musik]
warten
auf den hirntod für die angehörigen eine
strapaze
schlimmstes ins wort nachts weil meine
ferien sind als pflegerin oder pflegen
sich sofort wird mal denn wenn gomez und
mir hätte märkte immer auf dem
nachttisch oder wie immer bei sich aufs
handy unerwarteten 4 minuten das telefon
läutet und das lied immer da und das
sehr intensive und sehr schwierig sei
48 stunden zwei nächte zwei tage sie
können endlos scheinen tatsächlich lief
die zeit ab ohne das gehirn tod eintrat
es kam nicht zur organspende sicherlich
ein gewisser frust auch da man hat sich
das ziel gesetzt im organ erhalten eine
therapie und hat erwartet dass der
patient dass der hirntod eintritt
innerhalb des 48 stunden
man hat gespräche mit der familie
geführt hat sie darauf vorbereitet und
jetzt dieses ereignis nicht ein
innerhalb dieser
innerhalb dieses zeitlimits und ja es
ist ein gewisser fluss da und aber jetzt
heißt das hat auch mit der familie zu
reden und die neue situation in der wir
uns jetzt befinden zu besprechen dass
die gesetzte frist verstreicht kommt
durchschnittlich etwa jedes sechste mal
vor
in diesen fällen wird ein leben
vergeblich verlängert die therapie der
patienten bald werden die maschinen
abgestellt
kurz darauf wird der patient sterben
[Musik]
zwar ist eine organspende nach dem
kreislauf tod unter gewissen
voraussetzungen möglich diesen prozess
hat vor kurzem auch das inselspital
eingeführt aber in diesem fall wurde
davon abgesehen
patrick von reding und seine frau sind
im reinen mit dem geschehenen jetzt
stunde zwischen den die sind sehr
speziell und das werden wir niemals
eigentlich zumute
aber rückblickend trotzdem ziehen ihre
wichtigkeit vorteile ganz unten also ich
würde mir für den weg entscheiden
[Musik]
insofern hätte doch nicht weil es
spannende er als person einfach darum
hätten sie auch der 40 stunden gewartet
[Musik]
unzen in der nähe von aarau eliane
gutzweiler wohnt seit letztem frühjahr
allein
sie lebt von der iv für den beruf fehlen
zurzeit die kräfte ich liebe einfach
sind neu stimmen oder stoppen
new york ist zeichnet für mich entdeckt
wurde lotte ist es humoli und jasko teil
ich liebe schuhe zieht wo sie oft und
ich weiß wenn ich irgend eine stunde
arbeit die wir bisher in genau das ist
vielleicht auch nicht der grund warum
das wetter so segen der öffentlichkeit
bist es noch weiter weg aber ja
probieren damit irgendein bis für mich
nicht beliebt wo sie nur um für ihre
tante nelly der hand wenn es darum geht
eine eigene familie wird sie nicht
gründen können die krankheit bestimmt
die lebensplanung
das ist nicht wenig wenn ich bekomme
einfach wir haben mit körper das gar
nicht das würde die körper gar nicht
schaffen auswerten einfach nimmer dem
spital geburt überleben werden als
andere und ja ich habe jetzt
mittlerweile mit dem sie haben ja
eigentlich schlau mit dem abgefunden
ich glaube mir um in der nächsten suche
über wenn die ersten kollegen
runde glaubt er wird für mich aufnehmen
so einfach wie jetzt
[Musik]
eliane gutzwiller ist oft unterwegs an
zu treffen mit freundinnen mit lena
bühler teilt sie die leidenschaft für
tattoos solange ich atme
das ist das erste tattoo dass sich
eliane stechen ließ für die zeit nach
der transplantation raten die ärzte von
neuen tattoos ab kennengelernt haben
sich die freundinnen bei instagram sind
freunde
zusätzlich stützt sie zu der familie ich
weiß nicht vielleicht hab ich dir wo im
spital eingeliefert
nicht nur logisch bist du krank bist im
hinterkopf die ganze zeit ich und habe
ich das machen will
als jemand jetzt sehen wir dass das so
der hauptbestandteil von der
freundschaftlich haben mit boni
warnungen trans passiert sehen wenn es
denn überhaupt das 24 stunden
das habe ich schon als kind gmbh dem er
so lange könne mit alles mitgliederzahl
mit sehe habe ich im qualitäts chor will
ich mittlerweile das 24 stunden das
thema auto
es sind strategien für das glück die
aliens wähler entwickelt hat
[Musik]
eine zweite lungentransplantation
schließt sie nicht ganz aus
aber sie versucht tag für tag zunehmen
immer wieder eine so groß plant für die
nächste periode die weiß dass wir sind
alle nicht unendlich und das unternehmen
eine stütze durch das neue kraftwerk
nahe dem sind hobbys anstecken und mit
allen sinnen erleben und darum auch ist
jetzt gerade
[Musik]
emmenbrücke
seit vier monaten ist mirja wieder zu
hause damit sie pünktlich ihre
medikamente nehmen kann macht sie sich
erst nach schulbeginn auf den weg
ihre mutter katja denkt oft an den
unbekannten organspender
du kannst nur du kannst du kannst
schweren sogar schuh sogar schöner raum
wir fahren das was jetzt studiere schon
dass hier der tag ist wie eine glucke
ich werde selber ein spender sie aber
probleme weil die mit leverage genetisch
und jetzt hat gesagt also zum beispiel
nähere und so kann ich schon
spenderleber nach weg mit spenden
das immunsystem ist gedrosselt wegen der
medikamente die eine abstoßung des
fremden organs verhindern
das krebsrisiko ist wie bei allen
transplantierten menschen erhöht sie
muss sich deshalb gut gegen die sonne
schützen
jetzt kommt
[Musik]
mirja besucht die zweite klasse
bald sind sommerferien
[Musik]
nach und nach wird maria weniger
medikamente zu sich nehmen müssen
langsam im ersten jahr nach der
transplantation ist die gefahr von
komplikationen noch erhöht dann aber
sind marias aussichten auf ein fast
normales leben gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ausbildung beruf sport reisen und in
ihrem fall sogar eine eigene familie all
dem steht nichts im wege
die behandelnden ärztinnen sind sicher
dass die transplantation bei mirja der
richtige schritt war
obwohl die krankheit noch wenig
erforscht ist es gibt keinen grund für
die befürchtung dass es einen rückfall
gibt diese leber ist gesund wir haben
und alle für mirja gefreut und
wahrscheinlich haben wir früher schon
kinder mit dieser krankheit
transplantiert ohne es zu wissen
und dort gab es nie probleme nein ich
bin zuversichtlich dass die krankheit
nicht zurückkommen wird und mit alaba
transportation hat mit den super domina
effektives leonie gebiet ruhig die lage
beruhigt dass man mit als laden
versammelt und den völligen dritte mal
effektiv zum tod von dem iran geführt
hatte
martin rast kommt für das mittagessen
von der arbeit nach hause
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
maria hat sich von der operation erholt
und auch die eltern sind ruhiger katja
hat eine teilzeitstelle gefunden und
wird bald wieder arbeiten gehen
[Musik]
da gibt es aber nur einen zähler holen
das hat jetzt machst du auch schon einer
shopping queen die lungenkrankheit copd
beschränkt den bewegungsradius von
christian reutemann 1 15 uhr in der
virtuellen welt hat der raum des spiels
auf dem team mit achim aus berlin der
vom gamer kumpel zum freund geworden ist
rund fünf stunden pro tag verbringt
christian reutemann mit gameloft
zusammen mit achim optisch sehen also
über video wie christi und einmalig auch
deswegen sofort zu ihm gesagt haben
jetzt ja nicht weil ich ein bisschen hat
auf der lunge kann so ein bisschen
nachfühlen die qualität und die passt
kann usa drücken alle daumen
das ist gut wird
ok danke für den hinweis oh es ist alles
abgeerntet alle felder im richtigen
leben lässt sich christian reutemann die
lebensmittel liefern
selbst das kochen wird zur anstrengung
und die krankheit bestimmt auch die
menüwahl wie die kohlehydrate locker ist
eigentlich das heißt nur dass eine
heißluft fritteuse hilft fed zu sparen
wenn man schwer ist operation mit tory
führer hätten bmw ford ries seit darüber
später werde das bedeutet im inneren
körpergröße gewicht und das 1 1 kilo
jetzt bin ich voll 40 also man ans ziel
wenn respekt ab so dass wir für einen
skoda drohen ins koma und das ist dann
optimal für kooperation auch christian
reutemann ist iv rentner immer wieder
wird er von panikattacken erfasst gerät
in atemnot beginnt zu hecheln und es
dauert stunden bis er sich beruhigt wenn
dies nicht gelingt ruft er die ambulanz
mit dem mono 45 zurückfahren werde 50
prozent zur krankenkasse aber so ein
satz kosteten haltestelle musikstunde
2500 das mal vorstellen was sich uns mal
eigenen sack bezahlen
[Musik]
der tod durch ersticken durch langsame
ersticken der macht mir angst dass
entweder die krankheit
das ist schon mit grund warum dass ich
mich zu dem schritt für
transplantationen täter an
klar es geht wird exit
mit dennoch nicht ob in den sand gesetzt
würde ich eigentlich nur apple will
christian reutemann ist auf ein
spenderorgan angewiesen sowie 1400
andere menschen in der schweiz seit
jahren bemüht sich der bund die
spendebereitschaft der schweizerinnen
und schweizer zu erhöhen ohne
durchschlagenden erfolg
ich glaube viele können sich nicht
vorstellen wie das ist der mann wirklich
ums überleben kämpfte
ich habe von meiner transplantation auch
nicht darüber nachgedacht einen
organspendeausweis zu bei mir zu tragen
es gibt so viel übt ob es weiter unter
dem himmel oder sich eine feste und die
hatten bringt es werden spenden oder und
der schlussrampe aber die akteure die
griechen jetzt machen wir mal gescheit
lies durchgeht sich so viele die danken
es ihnen sie werden
tastet werden auch um dort die wurzeln
jetzt mehr oder umfeld blieben
das sind alles war aber gemeint also es
gibt auch als richtig um des vfb in eine
nächste familie hetzel übt wo das nie
trendforscher vorständen organe nach dem
tod spenden
das okay aber sie einst menschen sind
schäden und ich muss nach wenn es denn
so wäre das mit müssen entscheiden was
er acht hatte oder sie 8 hat die welle
und das ich finde frauen für antigone
tagen ein höchst erkennen
ja oder nein im nationalen organspende
register das vor gut einem jahr
aufgeschaltet wurde haben sich bis jetzt
70.000 menschen eingetragen
ja oder nein
ein entscheid steht auch auf politischer
ebene an eine volksinitiative verlangt
dass grundsätzlich jeder schweizer
spender ist wenn er sich nicht
ausdrücklich dagegen ausspricht
[Musik]
die wichtigste botschaft ist welcher
informieren wenn doch gut informiert was
heißt spannend was heißt transplantation
und entscheidet als er würde machen
sollte de als organ müsse über und was
er je wieder machen wenn nicht in der
situation sind dass er spenden würde
würde das sogar oder nicht
maria rast lebt mit einem spenderorgan
[Musik]
und hat wie die gleichaltrigen kleine
und große träume ein welpe als
gesellschaft für rocco
[Musik]
baltes
das ressort krankheit niemals
selbstverständlich eigentlich habe ich
nur die zukunft ja
[Musik]